clock welcome to this video let's see
I'm in this big slump ear to 145 and I
want back absolutely so I'm making a
real conscious effort TM to check to
concentrate and win this game and the
next ones as well so one of my main
openings here and blitz let's see it's
taking time right here hmm let's early
so c5 is the most common move b6 also
possible d5 not to move our like very
much but possible as well c5 is the main
move by what is he doing him AI can just
took ages 45
ok so we get this classical structure
with them oh he plays very quick see
form this is actually how calzon played
in the World Championship match against
island with the idea see form but it was
at a different spot in this game White's
bishop was on e to not on d3 so he
couldn't retreat to F to add to see to
this is actually a version of this which
looks very good for wide okay he can try
to get in b5 and so on I wonder I should
stop the time and I think I can
concentrate on f3 for first the big
problem with the move c4 it is that it
releases the tension the tension on on
the queenside okay can I get late for
here takes 93 i think i can and only
later take one you fall
so next move I'll take you form and get
this this good center at least I didn't
see anything what you could do against
it yeah this is very nice and now Bishop
g5 yes getting this aggressive replaced
so there are many good movie 5 maybe
maybe five open up the diagonal and I
have night age 594 some some attractive
moves yeah the sets up sets up the idea
of night xe5 but I can just go here
right
so even Bishop a4 as a move here Bishop
a phone it's not it's not helping much
though okay I wonder ever should take is
seven yeah come on let's not be too too
sophisticated here
ok trying to try to keep it simple if he
exchanges I take on f5 form with both
pieces leading to a good position I
probably had something better before but
it's it's still a pretty pretty nice
position yeah Queen g4 on Wham now this
this also gets Bishop before in the in
the mix attacking b7 now that's just
pile up on the FR maybe
now it's Roy h5 I don't know how do i
get the strongest possible to tech here
I go here maybe I need to make him
weaken structure a bit with g6
look f6 is this helping not sure
threading on f7 now I believe Oh cakes
hmm yeah it's nice but am i winning hmm
not really Queen f3 in order to get in
Bishop g5 or what's the way to play this
maybe also here yeah this is also not
bad just controlling and avoiding any
before moves with attacking a 3 now
that's not good I should have counted
that really
I got far more activity than he should
have gone far more
as getting a look be true even not good
time warning how to play
I have some activity of course with with
the rook here who is still threatening
would be one oops still threatening that
ah don't really want to play quindi one
but maybe I must do that I've lost
controller with us again I don't believe
it amazing amazing how that you can play
chess really amazing
I'm lost the app simply Queenie three
years is killing me ah resign i believe
over I mean I mean this I should really
I don't know how can you not win this
position it's it's really hard to do but
I managed I absolutely managed I'm up to
here it's it's it's it's even good for a
while yeah I mean I played it like a
total idiot yeah you shouldn't you
should never get there it's still
winning I just need to do this and King
h2 and that's it yeah just secure the
king bishop to d5 at the end i win the
pawn and of course this this is totally
winning and it's not even something I
mean I'm not winning this I mean am I
drunk or anything even this is I mean
the copies are plus foyer in an equal
material position but ok this is this is
not a good way to play i'm one minute up
and clearly better and a minute managed
to lose this and its really great yeah
it keeps an advantage the position is so
good you can play a ton of crab moves
and still win but if you play a couple
of crap moves too many you lose and i do
that amazing absolutely amazing and I
mean he run right into this ideal setup
I mean it's like a dream yeah this
position it's what oh come on wow what
what am I doing here can I stop this
this losing streak I have no idea
maybe play something different entirely
I can't do that in the next game thanks
for watching